foreign
hi everyone welcome to our homeroom live
stream
uh sal here from khan academy i do have
one announcement i think we've already
made this on social media and email but
just to make sure everyone's on the same
page
today was supposed to be the day that
we're going to have dr
fauci on i know myself and everyone here
is probably very excited about that
uh unfortunately unfortunately uh he had
to cancel for today but it got
rescheduled
till friday so same time on friday
hopefully we're going to have dr fauci
so continue to be very excited about
that
and my apologies for those of you all
who have uh showed up today and might be
somewhat disappointed only to see me
so once again dr fauci is going to be on
friday not today today
we're going to do an ask me anything so
start putting your questions in
on facebook and youtube and i will get
to them and before we do that
i will do my standard announcement
remind folks that khan academy is a
not-for-profit that we can only exist
with philanthropic donations from folks
like yourself so definitely
if you're in a position to do so go to
khan academy.org slash donate
i want to give special thanks to several
organizations that stepped up
during uh the the kovid crisis the
school closures when they realized that
we were already running at a deficit
pre-kovid and that our expenses have
only gone up since then
special thanks to bank for america
google.org att fascinavardis and the
amgen
foundation uh even with that significant
support we continue to run into deficit
so if in a position to do so uh please
think about making a donation
so with that i'm eager to answer all of
your questions and i'll say it a couple
of times because i think a lot of people
were going to tune in for
uh dr fauci today he has as i already
mentioned he has been rescheduled
until friday so we look forward to that
but i have a couple of questions that
have already been backed up from the
last ama so i'll start with those
and then but be sure to put whatever
questions you have underneath
whatever the message boards on facebook
and youtube so
there's a question here from anam khan
from youtube how did you come up with
the idea to make khan academy
give the gift of education for un
underfunded areas of the world
uh well adam i've talked about this
before i talk about it a lot
uh and you know they're kind of kind of
there's a long story about how khan
academy started it started as a project
where i was
tutoring my family and one thing led to
another and it soon became
clear that people who are not my my
cousins were benefiting from it
but very quickly i started to realize
that we're in a moment
well even pre khan academy even
pre-tutoring my cousins
when you really and this is a thought
experiment i probably first went through
when i was in middle school or high
school i realized if you really
peel the onion on every issue in the
world
whether it is economic inequality
whether it is
insecurity around food or safety
whether it's gender issues race issues
if you peel them slowly but surely it
really does
often boil down to an issue of education
it boils down to an issue do people
have critical thinking skills have they
been able to
participate in the enlightenment so so
to speak
um and and and that was always in the
back of my mind so i always was
fascinated with education as a lever
like you could have an innovation in a
particular domain
but if you can allow hundreds of
thousands or millions or billions of
humans
to uplevel their potential that could
create innovation and progress
in thousands of domains and in millions
of different areas
and so you fast forward to when i was
tutoring my cousins and i started making
tools for them
software for them started making videos
for them i started to realize you know
the things that i'm doing for my cousins
in theory they could scale to the world
it wouldn't be simple but they could
they could scale to the world with help
well in partnership with many other
folks and so that was the first time i
said maybe this could
maybe khan academy could be an
institution for the world that does that
and
you know when i was operating at the out
of the same walk-in closet that i am
right now because of kovid
it was a little delusional for a guy in
a walk-in closet to say
what if we if i guess at the time it was
i what if i could create an institution
that could one day educate billions but
you know sometimes you have to make a
little bit of a delusional bet
but then put one foot in front of the
other and make progress and keep
chipping away at it and before you know
it as long as you are willing to keep
failing forward before you know it
you're reaching 10 people 100 people a
thousand ten thousand hundred thousand
million
ten million and you know today khan
academy has over 100 million registered
users and we're nowhere near done
uh there's billions of students for
generations to come
who could benefit from khan academy and
khan academy uh
is doing a lot of good work and it's
much more than me now
but there's a lot more that we can do to
support all these folks but
you know big picture that's that's where
the thinking came from for what what
khan academy should be
so from from
facebook well i'm getting a lot of
questions from cons my extended family
maybe
zarina khan interesting books this late
uh
these days looking for a recommendation
um
so the book that i am reading right now
and i don't recommend it for
maybe anyone under the age of 18 or 21
this was recommended by a friend of mine
it's named shantharam
it's and i'm not giving the book away
it's about a um an australian who
escapes from prison and then kind of is
in exile to some degree in india and how
he starts working with the
the the underworld in bombay and it's an
interesting book fascinating book it's
both
there's a lot of action but there's a
lot of philosophy as well but it's also
quite dark and and violent uh you know i
i tend to be a fan personally of like
the
disney pixar school of movies uh so
it's for me it's a little grittier than
what i normally uh what i normally look
at
uh i i will tell you one thing that i'm
really enjoying watching
these days which is closer to the disney
pixar uh flavor of entertainment uh i
i just finished watching the uh avatar
the last airbender series
uh with my children i think it's on
netflix uh and then we just
um i think we have to pay money for this
next one but now we're watching the
sequel which is the legend of korra and
i am somewhat uh
addicted to these to these i highly
highly recommend those i like them
because you know they're just good
character development
they have they actually have some
interesting philosophy in them
uh and and uh yeah there's just really
really good stories
uh other things that i've been reading
lately you know uh my close friends will
tell you and this you know i'm reading
this in
i guess you could say with a a
non-religious lens but really for more
of a philosophical lens
you know i've been reading a lot of
marcus aurelius
meditations uh very related to that you
know things like the dhammapada from
buddha
there's a lot of overlap between them
the bhagavad gita
and upanishads i've been going into kind
of a exploration
of i would say philosophy especially
eastern philosophies but stoicism
uh you know which is obviously a greek
and roman philosophical system
is actually quite quite close to i would
say the
underlying philosophy of the vedas or
buddha so those have been other areas
that i've been
spending a lot of time uh reading and
obviously that's related i've talked
before i've been meditating a lot and i
think there's a lot of
interesting insights about you know who
we are especially when you when you
start
to try to steal your mind a little bit
let's see
from youtube baumin dang says i'm in
middle school
how can i use khan academy for distance
learning
well uh baum in we're there for you
there's a couple of ways there's many
ways you can do it i mean easily in math
i would say go to khan academy
i don't know what grade you're unless
you're in seventh grade or eighth grade
or sixth grade
uh go to khan academy i would start at
the get ready for grade level course so
let's say you're
going to enter seventh grade i would
start with the get ready for seventh
grade course on khan academy i would
take the course challenge
if on that course challenge you get an
80 or 90 percent that means you're ready
for seventh grade
and then i would just go into seventh
grade if you've always been a little bit
precocious in math
then you could even take the seventh
grade course challenge and get credit
for what you already know
and then start working out working on
that at your own time and pace if you
got less than a seventy percent on the
get ready for grade level course
not a big deal just keep working on that
so you have really strong foundations
and then work on the grade level course
my suggested implementation for you if
you have no other support that hopefully
you know your parents or your teachers
can support you as well
but if you're able to put in even 30
minutes a day i think i think as a
middle schooler
you know monday through friday if you're
even able to go up 40 45 minutes a day
into khan academy maybe split it up into
two sessions of 20 minutes each
you will find after about a month or two
that you're making really really good
progress and
the important thing is when you do those
20 minutes try to focus on the problem
solving the videos are there for support
if you have trouble with something you
can look at hints see how a solution the
solution to whatever you might have
missed
but keep reflecting on what you're
working on use the videos to get
yourself introduced to new concepts or
clarify concepts that you're having
trouble
understanding but keep working on the
exercises i would i suspect that if you
keep doing that even over a few months
you're going to notice a very big
difference
in your confidence in mathematics and
and how far you've been accelerating if
you
and you just keep doing that i think
regardless of where you start within a
year you'll be
ahead of where uh you need to be so
that's in math
and you know your middle school student
we have a lot of high school science
i do think some of the high school
science could be uh
consumable by you i would say especially
biology
uh i would so that's something to
explore uh some of the biology content i
think some of the early chemistry
content on khan academy you could also
start looking at
the physics you need a little bit more
math if you're precocious in math and
you know a little bit of
a little bit of algebra and trig then
you really need to do quadratics in the
basics of trigonometry in order to
engage in our physics course but i would
say the chemistry and biology for sure
and then on the humanity side that's
where you know my record we don't have
as much for you
as a middle school student uh we do have
some beta english and language arts
uh things that you can do to practice
reading comprehension what i do
recommend actually now that i think
about it is
you could and i'm not saying you know
i'm not trying to be a tiger cousin
telling you take an sat when you're in
middle school although there are some
programs that if you take
the sat in middle school you can get
into some summer camps and
and scholarships and whatever else but i
would say our sat practice which covers
reading writing and mathematics it
actually is really good to start as a
middle schooler
once again not because you need to take
the sat when you're in seventh or eighth
grade
but because some of those concepts the
easier questions on the sat are actually
roughly at
a middle school level and so if you get
practice with that it'll stretch you a
little bit
into kind of more advanced middle school
and high school topics
and then you'll have really good
development at least on the baseline
reading comprehension grammar and then
on the math as well you could do the sat
work or you could do the khan academy
work
i think if you did that during social
during covid uh you will
you'll be quite you'll you'll you'll be
doing all right and then i would
supplement that
or on top of that i would make sure to
be doing some regular reading
every day do some reading for fun read
some newspapers magazines and do some
regular writing
whether it's journaling try to force
yourself write a weekly blog post and
email it to all your family for so they
give
feedback you know just things that you
care about uh just get in the habit of
writing about it
i think if you do that handful of things
uh you're going to be in good shape
uh as as we go through this very
difficult period
so from youtube a space z
says sal how are you coping with
quarantine uh thanks for asking az
so you know if i'm honest i almost feel
guilty i feel very blessed
um quarantine has been kind to me
my children school has done a wonderful
job of keeping them with
um kind of distance learning keeping up
with them
my my wife has been incredibly
supportive many of y'all know she's a
physician
uh but you know she's able to work uh
three days a week so two days she's able
to
help um you know i'm here in the house
with the kids but obviously i'm
i'm i'm kind of you know super into my
work a lot of that time so
it really helps that my wife is here two
days a week and then my mother-in-law
lives with us
and uh and you know i know the
mother-in-law stereotype can go
in different directions but i have a
very very very good mother-in-law
and and she definitely um is a great
person to have around and and is really
great with the kids and and help support
uh our entire family
and and so i feel uh very fortunate on
that level
uh i think on the khan academy on my
work level
you know there's some puts and takes i
know it's been hard on many people in
the organization especially with
child care issues our organization
itself has done a good job we always had
a lot of distributed employees so
this was kind of natural for us to do a
lot of our work in a distributed or
remote way uh
i think you know it khan academy has had
a very big role to play
uh in this coveted world so you know we
definitely have a lot to do and i
you know in some ways feel lucky that
that there's a there's a role for us to
play to help people
to keep help folks keep learning uh
during social distancing
uh many of you all know i'm not a big
fan of uh of of planes
i like i like travel once i get to the
place that i'm getting to
i like looking at new places and
exploring new places and meeting new
folks but i really don't
like planes if i'm very honest with you
i just don't like them
for for many many many reasons um and so
i do consider it a little bit of a
blessing that i haven't had to get on a
plane in many many months
in fact i consider that a massive
blessing um
and uh um yeah so overall you know
considering what's going on in the world
i consider myself very lucky but you
know some of this is sitting very close
to home one of my
one of our good friends her father um in
maryland
passed due to kovid so you know it's not
like this is you know
this is a real thing that's happening um
to folks all around but but relatively
speaking i'm i
you know i'm i'm doing just fine uh but
but thanks thanks
thanks for asking so let's see
um there is from youtube
prisha b says what should i say to a
person who thinks that being
knowledgeable
is just getting good grades
um well
you know well if no matter what you're
you're asking me about one thing
you know you learn over time is it it's
hard to
it's hard to change someone um so you
know
there might not be anything that you
could tell them that would you know
overnight make them change
how they perceive the world getting good
grades is helpful
uh but really you know getting good
grades is a mechanism or a means or a
incentive mechanism hopefully to get
knowledge
and i think what you're implying is
there are some very knowledgeable people
who
who might not have the best grades or
didn't have the best grades and there
are some people who had very who have
very good grades
who might not be you know wise to the
world
so to speak uh is what i think you're
going at and these things don't actually
you know they might be correlated but
they're not a you know they're not as a
strong correlation as as
maybe your friend uh might might imply
so
i think um you know well if you could
show them the video of what i'm about to
say which is
uh you know i've always optimized my
life i
actually i i got mostly a's but i always
optimized for the learning
i was always more about hey this is
interesting let me learn it i'm curious
about it
and my grades will be what they are and
you know i got my share of a minuses and
you know i i got a b here and there uh
and
uh but i like and it was usually i got
the a minuses or the b's because i
wasn't
trying to optimize for the grade i was
out trying to optimize for the knowledge
which usually correlated with the grade
uh but i think uh that made school way
more interesting for me
and it and it um it it it gave me a
really strong foundation i think of
curiosity and being able to connect
things in the world
and i also think you know what even when
you think about things like college
admissions
you know there's sometimes a notion that
you know if i get one
b or even one a minus i'm out of the
running and i know college admissions
and things like that they're super
competitive or even certain jobs your
gpa has to be you know a certain
threshold for you to look at it so
grades
matter in that but i found that if your
grades are decent
or quite you know good but maybe not
absolutely perfect
but you are able to show real capability
and curiosity and knowledge in other
areas
that is really you know shines in
certain ways stands out in certain ways
that you'll be at least as successful as
you know the absolute
uh perfect grades so you know i'm not
anti-grades
you should definitely do what you can
get them as you know people do look at
those things
uh but they're they're uh maybe they're
necessary but they're not sufficient i
would say if you really want to
appreciate the beauty and the mystery of
the world
so let's see and i'll say frankly a lot
of the knowledge that i have i've gotten
after i left the school system so
i'm not being graded anymore so if you
want to stay knowledgeable you have to
keep wanting to learn
even when no one's grading you all right
so let's see other questions
um from facebook cecilia loong says hi
sal
would love to hear more about your
meditation what you do
where does where does your thought go
how long how did you find it before and
after etc
well uh thanks for the question cecilia
and you know i'm i i wanna i like to be
careful on on this live stream i don't
wanna turn into
you know someone on a soapbox you know
just telling people about my
my meditation et cetera et cetera but
you know what actually got me in i was
always kind of intrigued by meditation
i've always heard about it
uh when i was younger i i tried it and i
just didn't make sense to me i'd be like
okay i sit quietly and my brain's like
why are you doing this this is a waste
of time
and your thoughts start wandering so it
never really made a lot of sense to me
and then you know y'all just heard that
i don't like planes and if i'm very open
with you
like you know it was planes it's it's
there was a little bit of the fear
flying i did always come to terms with
death before getting on a plane
so i've come to terms with death many
times i think
uh but more than that actually it was
actually the claustrophobia for me
uh and i actually didn't even know what
claustrophobia was
you know i i knew what it was i knew
people had fear of small places but i
never understood what a phobia was
until i started to experience it uh
myself
when and you know people say it often
hits you in your late 30s or early 40s
oftentimes if you're a parent you know
whatever claustrophobia or anxiety or
whatever
you might call it you know we could we
could theorize why maybe
as a parent you're always anxious as to
what might go wrong with your children
and then that that kind of hardwires
those circuits but for whatever reason
about five six years ago i never liked
planes but about five six years ago the
claustrophobia got quite bad
or i would get on a plane and all i
could think about is wow i have to sit
in this plane for the next five hours
it's like this capsule i can't get off
of it and then your brain just starts
doing these very irrational things you
know a part of your brain thinks
hey brain you're being irrational chill
out just you know
watch a movie and read a book and take a
nap and you're going to be in new york
before you know it but it's a very
unpleasant feeling for anyone who has
gone through that it's arguably one of
the worst feelings
uh you can have and um
i was talking about this with a board
member of mine who has to travel frankly
way more than i i have to travel
and he says well you know i actually
have had the same issue
uh and a meditation really helped and i
was like okay well i'm
i'll try it you know i i i i
you know i didn't want to resort to
having to do any you know
medication or anything like that if i
didn't have to so i'm like let me let me
try
let me try meditation and so uh uh you
know
on his recommendation i downloaded the
headspace app and i started doing that
somewhat religiously you know i did you
know
10 minutes a day for uh two three months
and i kind of started getting into that
pattern and then i started to actually
see the benefits of it that it really
um got your mind stilled instead of
allowing your mind to kind of race in a
bunch of different directions
you do uh as you get more and more
practice get to a spot you know not all
the time my mind still wanders
but more often or more common than not
now
i'm able to get my mind into a place
where it's kind of still and
there's there's kind of that this
thought and when when you do that
regularly
you're less likely to get worked up
you're less likely to get anxious
you know even now if i'm at work or in
other areas and you know
a debate is happening that normally i
would get very worked up about now i'm
much more
zen about it i'm like look sal you know
do what you need to do but don't don't
get too too worked up you know these
these thoughts aren't you this
you aren't defined by whether you win or
lose this debate um
etc so so anyway that's how i got into
meditation i would say after a few
months i kind of just
you know i guess you could say graduated
from the app uh
and and now i do uh at least i try to do
at least 30 minutes a day
and um you know i just sit quietly
uh with you know upright posture and and
um
you know i do kind of a a body scan so
to speak just become aware of my
surroundings but then i try to just
you know still still my mind and just
kind of sit in that
in that moment and my mind definitely
does
still gravitate to oh you got to do this
for work oh you forgot to take out the
trash oh why did that person say that to
you the other day where did they
do they mean what you think they said so
your brain your brain
your brain definitely wanders but then
the other key is laugh it off
a lot of people take meditation a little
bit too seriously and then they it
becomes stressed out like you know you
start meditating and there's like a
lawnmower outside you're like oh lawn
mower i can't stand the lawn more
and then obviously that defeats the
purpose what you really should do is
like oh that's interesting there's a
lawnmower
a lawnmower is part of this reality how
how nice so
the more that you smile externally and
internally while you meditate and the
more that you're accepting
of whatever sensations uh whatever
thoughts come about you don't try to
fight him
he's like oh look at that thought that's
not the most positive thought but it's
one of the thoughts so
here thought why don't you move on a
little bit i think that the healthier it
can be
so um from facebook
melanie cashore asks how can i as a
parent instill or encourage curiosity in
my 8 and 10 year olds
thanks and please expand to older ages
too so you know it's interesting because
i actually think all kids have curiosity
pre pre-installed so to speak so i don't
think you have to instill them with it
there are
it's already there i think what you need
to do is give space for it
and not um squeeze it out and
uh you know most kids the way you give
space for it is when they
want to take an old toilet paper roll or
a box and they want to make something as
a parent and i have to remind this
myself all the time i
you know half the time me or my wife
were like oh we're busy we have to go to
this thing or you're late for this
practice or
i'm busy don't bother me you know wait
why are you making a mess over there
you know these are natural parent things
to do every now and then and i i have to
admit i'm not
great at this i often fall into what i
just described i'm like wait wait
this is really cool what my daughter
wants to do she wants to
cut up that thing that i was about to
throw away and make this thing
maybe i should sit down with her and
work with her a little bit um
you know okay they want to maybe they'll
make a little bit of a mess if they try
to take those paints and do this with it
on the kitchen counter and this and that
but
maybe a little bit of that's okay and i
and you know i i don't practice what i
preach all the time
just to be very clear you know i'm even
thinking about some
times in my own head over the last week
where i probably shut down my kids
creativity by telling them
hey hey no don't make a mess over there
wait wait we just cleaned the room or
wait wait why do you wanna why are you
digging in the trash
why are you taking that box out i just
flattened it you know like
whatever else so i think giving that
space for them
is key i think giving you know sitting
down with them on the ground
and doing it with them i actually think
there's a lot about modeling creativity
for them
you know a lot of adults kind of think
they're past the age where they should
sit down and draw
they should sit down and write a poem or
sing a song or compose a song
so that's another area you know i think
a lot of our
what in theory are creative pursuits
like um
playing a musical instrument or uh or
or visual arts in our goal-oriented
world
oftentimes become less creative where
you just you know in the musical
instrument okay now play a harder piece
okay now play a harder piece
learn to you know learn this technique
learn that technique well really
the musical instruments are about
creative expression uh and so
you know i think the more that we can
emphasize say young piano learners to
also compose their own ph pieces
which you don't see in piano class you
know so you know even my son has a great
piano teacher and he's doing a great job
but you know
i definitely encourage my son compose
your own pieces this is about expression
this is not just about being able to
play a more difficult piece a little bit
faster with a little bit more
technical sophistication that's useful
too that's going to build your
underlying skills but there's a whole
creative aspect to this
i would say even in you know in math a
lot of what you might learn
these are the these are the the
techniques these are the tools
but math is also a creative field and so
you know always have some fun enriching
problems to do you know
me and my kids we've been doing some
number theory which obviously isn't in
the common core standards or anything
but they're just these interesting logic
puzzles and number theory puzzles
uh that you have to be you have to kind
of a creative mindset to try to think of
a solution or try to think of a proof so
yeah i would say model it with them
participate with them and
you know get out of their way a lot of
times and i would also say don't over
schedule them
uh this you know creativity is
oftentimes a byproduct of boredom
so a little bit of boredom uh is is good
and over over time any human being who's
sufficiently bored will figure out
something to do and that usually is a
creative activity
so this is this is from
the other questions um from facebook
julie ramos jones i have a junior in
high school who will be starting
distance learning in august
what can i do to help her succeed
accomplishing her graduation
requirements through distance learning
so julie i don't know all of all of your
uh all of your daughter's circumstances
so i think on the learning side a lot of
the advice that i gave to the middle
school student
a couple of minutes ago i think would
apply to your daughter
you know math we've got her back
whatever level she's at whether she's at
trigonometry pre-calculus calculus stats
work on khan academy i would say two
30-minute sessions
a day would be incredible uh hopefully
she has support from her school
or her peers or from you if she gets
stuck on anything
um actually there's this other effort
that i've talked about here before
called schoolhouse.world
which is a not a khan academy effort
it's a separate effort maybe one day it
becomes a khan academy effort uh
but it's to pair students who need help
with the subject
especially in math we're starting in
math but eventually might go to other
subjects and volunteer
tutors running group tutoring sessions
so that's another layer of support
that we might be able to also provide or
that you know that this side project
might be able to provide
schoolhouse.world so between khan
academy
she should be able to get enough
practice in math and then get these
other supports
and then in science we also have got our
back on you know we have high school
and ap level physics chemistry biology
econ also in the humanities american
history and government and politics
i'd say all of that content is perfect
for the the age that your daughter's at
if the question is around credit you
know this is going to be really
interesting this year
uh where colleges are going to have a
lot less information a lot of schools
have gone to pass fail
or they're just passing everyone because
of you know inequity
access of devices and things and so i
think um the successful students are
going to have to come up with alternate
ways of showing colleges
uh that they've they've made it and or
that they've not made it that they've
they've
reached the they've met the requirements
and that they know the material
meeting the requirements most if you're
thinking about like the state university
systems most state university systems
have
an alternative way to prove your
competencies
uh most private schools at the end of
the day tend to be
less rigid about most project colleges
tend to be less rigid about their
requirements more that they want to see
are you college ready
are you you know are you a caring person
who wants to help the world
are you know what are your capabilities
in different subject areas and there's a
lot of ways you can show that you can do
that with sct
maybe you can even show your mastery we
had um
jim nandor from the universe chicago on
this live stream a couple of months ago
and you know
jim and i have been talking about well
he would love to see kids submit their
khan academy mastery because
not only would that let's say your
daughter is able to get 90 mastery on
calculus on khan academy
if she wanted to apply to university
chicago and she submitted that
from jim's point of view not only would
that be a pretty good indication that
she knows her calculus
but it also is an indication that she's
k that she's a self-learner she has a
lot of agency
you know even in a tough time like kovid
when a lot of things are hit and miss
she's able to to drive her own learning
forward which i think would look good
i also think you know people don't use
video
enough a video is a great way to
advocate for yourself one thing that i
do and the few times you know every now
and then
uh whether you know it's a student that
i've worked with or whatever wants a
recommendation i actually make
recommendation videos for them because
it becomes
it's you can't fake that it's it's like
you know it's not like someone else
wrote it and just signed it and i would
say you can advocate yourself in that
for yourself in that same way if you can
create video artifacts that
show things that you've created that
show you explaining concepts
then that only adds to your to your
portfolio to show that
not only do you know the material not
only have you done cool creative things
but you also know how to communicate
your work uh
and and i think that is also another way
to self-advocate frankly at any age at
any age so
anyway those are my my ideas i am trying
to talk to
state leaders college folks for
what if khan academy itself mastery on
khan academy could count
towards the state requirements for
graduation or towards the state
university requirements
uh you know maybe there's a way that a
teacher can validate that it's the
student's work
proctor them some way maybe you could
take a course challenge on khan academy
and
talk out loud on audio while you're
doing it and submit the audio too so
people like look i clearly did this work
i'm thinking out loud doing every
problem that's hard to fake
i saw stuff like that but it's going to
be an interesting challenge especially
if covid lasts
and it looks like it very well could
last for another year or even longer
so we're all out of time this is these
these always go
um these always go super
fast so i'll answer one last question
from facebook selma malik says my
eight-year-old is interested in coding
but i don't want to encourage too much
screen time he likes scratch what else
should he do how old are your kids
well my kids are 11 9 and 5 and a half
and
they are also into coding they've used
scratch they've used tinker they've used
the khan academy coding
i you know screen time is an interesting
debate
i think if a child is doing really
creative things
like writing on on a screen like writing
a paper
or a blog post or if they're editing
video
or if they are coding that is a good use
of screen time and so for a child that
is eager to code
i would say yes definitely let them code
but the more important thing is make
sure that they're also getting
other healthy things in their life
making sure that they're spending a good
amount of time
getting their vitamin d out in the sun
running around getting breathless
as much as possible in this covet 19
socially distance world
they're able to interact with other
people have social connections
that they have just free time to
themselves that there's time with the
family that they're eating right
sleeping right
if they're doing all that stuff coding
is great and it's a great outlet for
creativity
you know i remember i i didn't i didn't
i you know i didn't have
well i didn't start coding until later
uh and
but it was an incredible outlet for
creativity for me and
sometimes when i was really into
creating a new game or
or a new app you know i would spend 12
hours straight
and i don't and i think almost anyone
who who's really immersed in a creative
field will tell you they spend 12 hours
straight at least sometimes when they're
really
in the zone and there's nothing wrong
with that in fact i think that's good
once again as long as they're eating
right they're getting their exercise
they're running outside they're not only
on a screen all day
um then i think you know you know the
bad screen time is where you're kind of
just vegeta
you know watching something and you're
just kind of you know
whatever that that's probably the stuff
that you know watching people on package
toys or something that that can be or
worse uh
that that could be a little less
productive uh but anyway uh
thanks everyone these are really good
questions i'll try to get to them uh on
the next ama
uh just a reminder to everyone who was
expecting to see anthony fauci today
uh we they had to uh reschedule to
friday so
still very excited about that
conversation we're gonna be talking
about obviously
a covid and school closures related to
kovid
so very very excited about that
conversation so thanks everyone for
joining i really enjoy these ask me
anythings and uh look forward to seeing
y'all on friday
you